It goes without saying that the SCP Foundation
has a storied history with ancient anomalous
groups of interest.
From the metal-worshiping Mekhanites, to the
fire-loving Brazen Heart, to even the brutal
empire of the slave-owning Daeva, who swear
allegiance to the dreaded Scarlet King But
perhaps the most dangerous and downright disgusting
of these groups are the flesh-worshipping,
disease-loving, body-warping Sarkicists.
The Sarkicists believe in returning humanity
to a nightmarish primordial state.
They utilize anomalies to achieve this goal,
such as the horrible SCP-610, also known as
The Flesh That Hates, a disease that converts
human beings into mindless beasts of twisted
flesh, driven to spread their disease further
and further.
The Sarkics were once a world superpower,
controlling much of modern-day Russia and
eastern Europe from the holy capital of Adytum,
a city ahead of its time, with towering blood-red
temples, wide, winding roads, and the Castle
of Grand Karcist Ion, an immense, blistering
red and gold structure that was as beautiful
as it was imposing.
It would only make sense that the former area
of the Sarkic empire would host some of the
most ghastly of the Sarkic anomalies.
It should not be forgotten that while the
Sarkics are a Group of Interest for the SCP
Foundation, they are first and foremost a
religion – one with ancient practices of
blood and human sacrifice.
While the SCP Foundation is famed for its
containment procedures, when it comes to the
likes of actual deities entities, containment
isn’t quite as straightforward.
The standard “put it in a box until it stops
trying to get out” technique just won’t
cut it – the deities require specific practices
that sometimes go against the core values
of Secure, Contain, Protect.
Take SCP-2845 for example, this entity, known
as “The Deer” is a being that requires
an intense, deadly, and specific ritual to
keep it properly contained.
The SCP Foundation even had to outsource help
in containing this anomaly.
Anomalies such as these place The SCP Foundation
at a crossroads of action or inaction, and
when this issue is combined with a Sarkic
anomaly that could bring catastrophic results
should containment fail, they need to make
the difficult choice of letting the anomaly
stay where it is - without intervention - for
the safety of the world.
This nightmare started in the year 1916 , during
the battle of Transylvania of the First World
War.
As bullets flew and the smell of smoke pervaded
the noses of the scared soldiers, blood-lusting
beasts were waiting their time to strike,
staking behind the unnaturally curved trunks
of the trees that lived in the nearby Hoia
Forest.
Soldiers, armed with weapons and tactical
armor, were quickly and brutally attacked
and consumed by entities that would be known
as the ‘Pale Men.’
At the time, not much was known about these
‘Pale Men,’ and they were believed to
be a myth among the local populace meant to
scare invading soldiers from stepping on Romanian
land.
But, when 244 people go randomly missing in
a single night, with no obvious signs of death,
no bodies ever being found, and reports of
Pale Men dashing through trenches and within
the surrounding Hoia forest, the SCP Foundation
would surely have to intervene.
This would not occur until 1919, however,
as World War One raged on, diverting Foundation
attention away from these mysterious deaths.
Agents Fredrick Harper and Reece Gorman, posing
as military officials and local law enforcement,
began to speak with the locals around the
Hoia forest and the surviving soldiers.
While shell shock rocked the soldiers with
guilt and terror, Gorman was able to ascertain
that the soldier’s stories of the Pale Men
were too consistent to be a falsehood created
out of stress.
The pale men were described as living vampires,
more bat than human, and deadly fast, appearing
in quick flashes before dragging the unsuspecting
victims to their untimely deaths within the
Hoia Forest.
Meanwhile, Agent Gorman spoke with members
of a village within the Hoia Forest near the
battle site.
Their demeanor was cold, which was expected.
He was an outsider, speaking rudimentary Romanian
in an obviously foreign tongue.
The village people claimed ignorance, declaring
that they never heard stories of pale men
and did not subscribe to fairy tales.
Gorman, realizing he was unwanted, nearly
cut his losses before the elder of the village
stopped him.
This elder, an old man draped in hand-knit
scarves and red silks, invited the agent into
his home and gave him the truth.
These villagers were followers of Sarkicism.
The home of the elder was decorated with Sarkic
glyphs and paintings detailing the stories
of Yaldabaoth – the primary god of the Sarkics
– battling Mekhane – the legendary Broken
God.
On a lectern sat scolls and dusty tomes detailing
Sarkic history – from former kings to stories
of battles that were waged against the Mekhanites
and Daevites.
The elder explained that there was a Sarkic
god within the Hoia Forest, known as “The
Mother” who sends out her children to feed
and help her grow ever larger.
The village worshipped The Mother and tried
their best to keep her at bay by conducting
ritual sacrifices to her and her brood.
However, the advent of World War One led to
difficulties in continuing their rituals as
they were living in an active warzone and
the Mother’s children and their hunger were
impossible to control, leading to the unfortunate
deaths of the soldiers.
Agent Gorman was eventually able to convince
the elder to show them where The Mother resided
– a temple, superficially resembling other
Eastern Orthodox monasteries.
But this was no house of God that you or I
would recognize.
On the lower level, it contained an ancient
beast, starving for blood and sacrifice.
This place soon became designated SCP-2191,
otherwise known as The Dracula Factory.
New containment procedures were quickly enacted.
Twenty armed guards were placed around the
temple, with strict orders to dispatch any
entity that exits the structure.
Standard containment procedures for anomalous
buildings were enacted as well, preventing
all non-Foundation personnel from entering
SCP-2191 and authorizing the use of lethal
force when necessary.
Access to SCP-2191 has allowed Foundation
biologists to research the entities that were
known as the Pale Men.
These creatures were found to be genetically
human, but with a variety of alterations that
should have resulted in fatalities.
These entities were subsequently designated
as SCP-2191-1.
SCP-2191-1 entities appear to be more bat
than human, with large, conical ears that
end in sharp tips, upturned noses, and the
ability to communicate via echolocation.
This echolocation ability comes in handy,
as SCP-2191-1 are completely blind – their
eyes have recessed into their skulls and a
layer of skin has grown over them.
The entities also lack pigmentation, leaving
them starkly pale, appearing to be made more
of porcelain than flesh and bone.
These entities are predators, solely hunting
living human beings – ignoring human cadavers
or any non-human animal.
They hunt by spreading through the Hoia Forest
and chasing their victims.
Once caught, SCP-2191 entities will inject
their victims with a paralytic agent by stabbing
them with a sharp bone that has grown from
their wrists.
They will then unhinge their jaws, allowing
a leech-like entity to exit their mouths and
begin the feeding process by latching onto
the victim's neck.
This leech, designated as SCP-2191-2, will
first inject the body with digestive enzymes,
converting organ, muscle, and bone into liquid
before consuming the resulting fluids.
The feeding process can last anywhere from
20 to 50 minutes, depending on the size of
its prey.
These are highly skilled and sophisticated
predators, and while they lack the higher
intelligence of non-anomalous humans, they
make up for it in ruthless ferocity.
It would only make sense that the Foundation
would enact strict containment procedures
to avoid the loss of human life.
But while these containment methods worked
for a time, a series of anomalous events connected
to SCP-2191 transpired over the next 70 years.
The first event was in late September of 1932.
The Ierissos earthquake devastated the Chalkidiki
peninsula of Greece, leaving houses crumbled,
civilians homeless, and causing 490 reported
casualties.
Surveys of the damage conducted by the Greek
Government found that 126 people who lived
in the affected areas could not be accounted
for.
The question now arises, where are these missing
people?
Seven years later in 1939, this time in Turkey,
the Erzincan earthquake struck the country,
resulting in the catastrophic deaths of approximately
33,000 people.
Among the survivors, reports of a “great
serpent” were given from all who witnessed
the event.
The Foundation then intervened, posing as
members of an international disaster recovery
agency.
Reports from the locals remained the same
– a great serpent, a deep red and black
in color and incomprehensively massive, casting
dark shadow miles long, rose from the ground
at the onset of the earthquake and writhed
in the air as the Earth shook.
For a period of three years, nothing related
to SCP-2191 transpired and the Foundation
believed that the anomaly had gone dormant.
That was until an earthquake struck Vrancea,
Romania in 1940.
While casualties were low compared to the
earthquake in Turkey, reports from local survivors
had repeated claims that “pale men” attacked
the fleeing people as the earthquake occurred,
chasing after them and tackling them, never
to be seen again.
With a large-scale event like this and potential
witnesses to anomalous beings, the SCP Foundation
was risking a Broken Masquerade Scenario should
this information spread.
Broken Masquerade scenarios are considered
an XK Class scenario by the SCP Foundation
and as such, they employed a media blackout
and had newspapers state that the witnesses
of these vampire attacks were nothing but
superstition.
In March 1953 in Turkey, the Yenice-Gönen
earthquake led to the deaths of over 1,000
people.
The Foundation, once again posing as members
of an international disaster recovery agency,
interviewed survivors and attempted to find
any connection to the preceding events.
Reports from survivors again told a consistent
story, they witnessed the "arm of a blood-red
octopus" rupture from the earth when the quake
began , behaving similar to the “great serpent”
writhing in the sky, and reported that "pale
men" were seen attacking survivors in the
night as they searched for places to sleep.
These sightings of pale men persisted for
over a month after the earthquake before amnestics
could be distributed.
Another event occurred in March of 1977 in
Romania.
It was a similar story to all the others,
with over 1500 civilians dying as a result
of the Vrancea earthquake and 800 civilians
being declared missing.
Foundation officials embedded in the Romanian
government were told that reports of "pale
men" and tendrils pulling victims beneath
the ground began to surface, leading to media
blackouts and amnestic distribution as panic
spread throughout the region.
The Foundation couldn’t figure out what
was causing these events.
When they began instituting the containment
procedures around SCP-2191, no SCP-2191-1
entities were able to exit the temple without
being quickly dispatched.
So, how were these events occurring, especially
in areas so far away from the Hoia forest?
Could it be that the large creature seen breaching
the Earth was responsible?
The Foundation decided to return to the village
that originally told them about the temple
to interview their elder once more.
Doctor Judith Low was given permission to
conduct the interview.
She was a senior employee of the SCP Foundation
and had multiple doctorates in Sarkic History
and Sarkic Anthropology – her expertise
in the subject was unmatched.
Doctor Low had written multiple studies on
the Sarkic culture and understood that only
one thing satiates Sarkic Gods: Blood.
With this knowledge in mind, Doctor Low met
with Draga Negrescu, the current elder of
the village.
Draga was an old woman, wrapped in the red
silks and scarves as the previous elder.
Doctor Low began the interview and jumped
immediately to the subject, asking Draga what
she could tell her about the temple.
Draga replied, stating that the temple was
the home of what they called “The Mother.”
The Mother was not unlike a queen bee, as
she sends her drones out to collect blood
much like bees collect nectar.
Draga continued, stating that her village
acted as the beekeepers to The Mother, helping
the hive flourish and stay full before the
SCP Foundation intervened.
Draga expressed that it was imperative that
they would be allowed to continue their sacred
duty of satiating The Mother.
Doctor Low needed more information on who
exactly The Mother was.
Draga Negrescu told her that The Mother was
once a princess and the daughter of a Sarkic
Blood Empress in Adytum, the ancient Sarkic
capital.
She was a strikingly beautiful girl, wearing
the finest of clothes and had long, dark red
hair – a trait common to those with ancient,
royal Sarkic bloodlines.
When she walked through the streets of Adytum,
all eyes turned toward her.
The Grand Karcist Ion was struck by her beauty
and kidnapped the princess, claiming her as
his own.
She became his mistress.
While she first hated her position, she slowly
grew to worship Grand Karcist Ion as a god.
While Grand Karcist Ion is seen as a deity
now, he was not during his reign as the King
of the Sarkic Empire.
The princess begged to bear Ion’s children
as a result.
She was blessed by the Grand Karcist and was
planted in the Koia Forest to grow large and
wide.
Ion commanded the princess to bear as many
children as she could muster, and she did.
The princess birthed Ion’s children – the
pale ones – for all of eternity and would
let them feed as Ion would want.
Draga stated that she and her village are
no different than the pale men, as they were
tasked with keeping The Mother fed and satisfied.
Draga then let slip this chilling remark:
“The Mother and the land are now one.
Her earthen womb swells and soon she will
rupture.
All around you is tinder for the Gods.”
It seems as though the Foundation’s containment
efforts led to the deadly earthquakes and
deaths of thousands of people.
By stopping the practices of this village
to contain The Mother through ritual, they
had potentially caused an XK-Class end of
the world scenario.
One question remained, though: Where is The
Mother?
An investigation into the tunnel systems located
below SCP-2191 would lead to the answer.
Mobile Task Force units that specialized in
underground exploration, such as the Mole
Rats, were sent to the tunnel system below
the temple, armed with weapons to dispatch
any loose SCP-2191-1 entities.
These agents discovered a grisly sight, a
massive, writhing mass below SCP-2191.
Researchers, believing Draga’s story, ascertained
that this was The Mother, and designated it
as SCP-2191-3.
This entity is a massive, blood-red organism
buried deep beneath the earth where SCP-2191
stands.
The true size of the entity has proven entirely
impossible to measure, but root-like appendages
have been found to extend throughout the tunnels
below the Earth.
These appendages were found to secrete a toxic,
highly corrosive acid.
SCP-2191-3 uses this fluid to create tunnels,
which explains the odd tunnels below SCP-2191-2.
Measurements place the area SCP-2191 spread
to approximately 660,000 square kilometers
under the Balkan Penninsula.
For comparison’s sake, SCP-3000 - the amnestic-producing
eel god, Ananatashesha - is a measly 900 kilometers
in length at maximum.
With that in mind, now we can see the gargantuan
problem the SCP Foundation was dealing with.
SCP-2191-3 is sapient – meaning it has an
innate sense of understanding and self-awareness
– and exerts control over SCP-2191-1 and
SCP-2191-2 organisms via the release of complex
pheromones.
SCP-2191-1 entities act as feeder drones for
SCP-2191-3.
It has since been discovered that civilians,
native to several isolated villages in the
vicinity of Hoia Forest, have actively provided
human sacrifices to SCP-2191 as a means of
minimizing the seismic activity that occurs
when it is famished – and this worked to
satiate the entity and prevent further damage
to the Earth and its people.
The Foundation now stood at the crossroad
between active containment and allowing the
people who knew and understood the anomaly
to contain it themselves.
The Foundation motto is Secure, Contain, Protect,
however, if they allow Draga Negrescu and
her village to continue their sacrifices,
they will be unable to fulfill any of those
core values, but SCP-2191 will not be wreaking
havoc.
This dilemma led to the involvement of the
O5 Council.
A joint statement from them reads: There are
some who wish to believe that the Foundation
has never, nor will ever, cater to the designs
and desires of an anomalous entity.
Foundation efforts to contain SCP-2191 are
now thought to have inadvertently led to the
deaths of approximately 40,000 over 45 years.
The obvious choice would be to neutralize
the threat.
And we've tried.
The number of civilian and Foundation casualties
being well beyond acceptable numbers.
In order to contain the larger threat, we
must allow it to feed.
We are aware of the offense caused by this
procedure.
This is not the first time, nor will it be
the last, that the Foundation has been forced
to commit a lesser evil in the prevention
of a greater one.
We do believe that, in the end, our current
method is the most preferable - with regards
to both ethics and efficiency.
We are fully aware that every sacrifice feeds
SCP-2191-3, allowing it and its brood to thrive.
But we are not about to sacrifice the entire
Balkan Peninsula to neutralize that threat.
Not yet.
It was clear that the SCP Foundation had no
choice but to allow the villagers who lived
around SCP-2191 and The Mother to continue
their practices.
Upon their involvement, there was catastrophe
after catastrophe that would only stop once
the correct people – Draga Negrescu and
her villagers – could return to their way
of life and end the madness.
A final containment procedure was ordered
as a result.
The SCP Foundation would maintain surveillance
operations via the use of closed-circuit security
cameras, and drone footage.
All personnel of the SCP Foundation would
be prohibited from directly interfering with
SCP-2191 or the ritual practices of communities
within the vicinity of the Hoia Forest, which
include blood or human sacrifices to SCP-2191.
Exploration of SCP-2191 would only be allowed
by remote-controlled drones.
Lethal force is only authorized should SCP-2191
or any of the creatures that live beneath
it breach containment.
Should the Foundation fail in upholding the
ritual practices that keep The Mother at bay,
well…
Draga Negrescu said it best:
All around them is tinder for the Gods.
Now go check out “SCP-2783 - Silent Lamentations
of a Clockwork Goddess” and “SCP-1348
- Inner Sanctum” for more fascinating anomalous
locations!